hey youtubers it's Charlie so this week
for my Game of Thrones bonus video
there's there's so much Star Wars stuff
happening this week I'm going to be
talking about lightsabers I figured it'd
be good to talk about Valyrian swords so
I'm going to talk a little bit about
their history and A Song of Ice and Fire
and what they might be doing with them
in the future that is to say what george
RR martin and the writers of the TV show
are going to be doing with Valyrian
swords i mean it's not it's not like
they're going to start using them as
hammers or anything like that like well
we killed all the white walkers so i
guess we're just going to use these as
large dinner knives or something like
that but um i should say careful for
spoilers for everything that's happened
on the show so far and there is a new
round of the giveaway all you have to do
to enter is be a subscriber and leave a
comment on this video it's just a $20
Amazon gift card real simple so where
we're at right now in the narritive
george RR martin has not revealed how
Valyrian still is created it's still
meant to be this very rare resource
we've also learned about obsidian also
called dragon glass which has the exact
same effect on White Walkers so maybe
there is a correlation there a lot of
people want to believe that a critical
component in the creation of Valyrian
still are in the smelting of Valyrian
steel is obsidian like you added
somewhere in the process now that's like
an oversimplification smelting steel
becoming a mastered sword maker very
long very complicated process so I don't
think suddenly someone's going to figure
out how to make Valyrian steel on the TV
show like Samwell isn't just going to
like figure it out and then a bunch of
people are just going to start creating
thousands and thousands of swords
overnight it's more likely that if we
get our war for the dawn and season
eight or whatever season that ends up
coming in the remaining children of the
force would just start bringing more
shipments of obsidian to the wall so
they just start passing around obsidian
daggers
now we have to talk about him sitting a
little bit too but let's talk about
Valyrian steel first there are several
very famous swords that we've heard
about in the books and on the TV show
there are even more that are mentioned
but never seen the most famous is black
fire that is the ancestral blade of
succession of the Targaryen family it's
most commonly known as Aegon the
conquerer sword so the added context of
you know becoming the sword of
succession for the Targaryen family
really only started happening after he
became king of Westeros flurrying swords
by themselves incredibly rare incredibly
precious but you know you had like
social context where it's like okay the
king of Westeros always wielded this one
specific sort then it becomes something
even more special the last known
whereabouts were that it was
taken by bittersteel after the Blackfyre
rebellion the first Blackfyre rebellion
and then never seen again because the
black fires created the golden company
you could theorize that someone who is
still associated with the golden company
has possession or knows where the sword
might be but the TV show hasn't really
done the golden company so if they find
black fire the you know the ancestral
Targaryen blade then it's going to be
something that Varys tracks down as part
of the Targaryen restoration it would be
amazing I don't expect it but it would
be amazing if they presented Daenerys
with the sword before she goes back to
Westeros
I've seen a small part of the Jon Snow
fandom ask if he would ever will black
fire - like if he's secretly a Targaryen
wouldn't he wield the ancestral
Targaryen blade well no he would
probably still wield Longclaw so if you
want to fantasize about anybody wildung
Blackfyre fantasize about Daenerys now
as many different styles of sword there
are there are different styles of
Valyrian sword Georgia or Martin
describes black fire as a hand and a
half sword meaning like it's a little
bit longer than a bastard sword maybe
like a little bit longer than Earth
Keeper witch Brienne is currently
wielding the mountain would be a good
exception to that role like he wields a
sword that's way way bigger just because
he is physically so much larger moving
down the list there's dark sister
Martin describes that as a long sword
typically wielded by a female it started
with one of egg on the conquerors sister
wives and then was passed down
eventually to the Bloodraven
nobody knows if he took it with him when
he went to the wall initially in case
you didn't see the Bloodraven video that
I did a couple weeks ago i theorize that
it'd be very funny if bran were to find
dark sister just like sitting in the
root system somewhere underneath that
weirwood oh hey what do you know very
special Valyrian blade just happens to
be sitting around here there's Ned
Stark's blade ice which was melted down
into two different filarial swords
including Oathkeeper and widow's wail
it's a giant great sword but it's
supposedly only four hundred years old
so it's not as old as some of the other
Valyrian blades
speaking of which widows well I know a
lot of people are wondering where this
Valyrian blade is because Joffrey died a
lot of people think that it might have
been buried with him George our Martin
clarified that Tywin sent it to Casterly
Rock to be kept for Tommen to wait till
he was ready to wield it so breathing
easy it did not get buried with Joffrey
the other side of that equation both
keepers still walking around the north
with Brienne of Tarth killing other
would-be kings of Westeros next big
sword bright roar this is the ancestral
bleh
House Lannister way before Aegon
conquered the Seven Kingdoms King Tommen
the second when the Lannisters could
still call themselves Kings lost it when
he was questing to Valyria so presumably
the blade is somewhere in the ruins of
ancient Valyria Tyrians uncle actually
went to find it never came back or it
was destroyed in the doom of Valyria you
have to remember that Valyrian swords
are not completely indestructible
there's lady forlorn which is a
longsword that belonged to house Corbray
that's only mentioned in the sworn sword
that that's one of the Duncan eggs
stories nightfall is the ancestral blade
of house Harlem red rain is the
ancestral blade of house drum
lamentation which is the ancestral blade
of house Roy's vigilance is the
ancestral blade of House Hightower
orphan Maker is the ancestral blade of
house Roxton truth is the ancestral
blade of house regard which is actually
not a westerosi house they're from a
list there are still a couple families
in the east like a couple great wealthy
families who had their own Valyrian
blades including this really famous
Dothraki called cago corpse killer he
carried this Iraq which is one of the
types of weapons that Dothraki favor
Longclaw we know is the ancestral blade
of house Mormon which was given to Jon
Snow will probably remain with him
heart's pain is the ancestral blade of
house Tarly it is still wielded by
randyll Tarly so we know that they cast
him in season six it means we'll
probably get to see the sword and then
probably the most famous sword next to
black fire is actually not a Valyrian
sword at all it is dawn the ancestral
blade of house Dayne which unlike
Valyrian blades was not smelted from
anything on earth it was smelted from a
meteor even though Don is not made of
the same minerals as Valyrian swords it
still has the same effect is every bit
as strong as fillory and still because
the blade is passed down to the sword of
the morning the person born of house
Dayne deemed worthy to wield the sword
since there's no one that exists right
now that holds the title the sword still
presumed to be at Starfall waiting for
someone to come along so think of it as
being like Tommen with widow's wail now
there is a Dane who is the heir to house
Dayne in the books but like Tom and he
is really really young too young to
wield the sword the TV show hasn't done
the characters they could do whatever
they want to with the sword I'm assuming
that the TV show would just say that
it's still it's star fall 2 now
supposedly there's going to be a tower
joy flashback during season 6 Arthur
dane was there fighting Ned Stark using
dawn while Ned Stark was using ice so
presumably we'll get to see the sword
but it will only be in flashback so
here's my big question for you guys let
me know in the comments what is your
favorite sword from the books or from
the TV show and which one do you want to
see them bring on the show that we
haven't seen yet I feel like everybody's
waiting behind their computer monitor
say dawn dawn please bring dawn on the
show that's another question I get a lot
to like you know if dawn came on the TV
show would Jon Snow wielded no he
probably would not because he still has
long claw and they have the exact same
effect but it's all just speculation and
you have to remember that wins winner
isn't out so we'll probably some more
information about what's going on in a
world of Ice and Fire especially some of
the prehistory of the TV show so
hopefully that'll add some more context
what's going to happen tonight is is
there's going to be a Mark Hamill
lightsaber special on ESPN I know that
sounds really weird mark Hamill's like
I'm going to be talking about the
history of lightsaber technique so I'm
totally going to be doing a lightsaber
video later tonight the rest of this
week is definitely going to be Star Wars
heavy in terms of videos - for
understandable reasons I mean this is
like Star Wars season there's very
little else that is happening that is
not Star Wars there is some more
Deadpool stuff happening there's a
trailer coming for that really soon
there might be some other trailers
dropping but you can just follow me on
Twitter and Facebook for updates on when
videos are posting and if there's
anything specific you guys want me to do
for a game of Thrones and Game of
Thrones bonus videos just let me know in
the comments congratulations to this
week's giveaway winner Domingo Pineda
you win a $20 Amazon gift card just be
sure to private message me on the back
end of my channel so I can get your
contact info
why is wait for my next video in case
you haven't seen it you can click here
for the last Game of Thrones Season 6
teaser very surprises they're dropping
teasers and certainly and you can click
here for all my Star Wars videos thank
you so much for watching everybody let's
high five I'll see you guys tonight
you